I'm going to show you how to get your
first five customers in 10 steps the
wild world of YouTube has videos
everywhere telling you how to scale and
grow but I think people over complicate
it and so this is actually a sneak peek
from my new book 100 million dollar
leads which comes out 819 you can go to
acquisition.com forward slash leads
let's dive in so the first step to
getting this going is you need to get a
list
Alex you're damn straight you do number
one I want you to go to your email
account to pull all the contacts that
you have in there anybody that you've
ever messaged or emailed that becomes
list one list two is I want you to go to
every single social media profile that
you have go to your social media
profiles where you can direct message
people so if you have followers that you
can DM I want you to write down every
single one of those people list number
three pull out your phone
look for your contacts I want you to
export them list one is all your email
contacts list two is all of your Social
contacts and list three is all of your
phone and private personal contacts if
you add all three of those together you
will have a shitload more leads than you
thought you did you're like wait you're
gonna ask me to contact these people
slow down
not yet and we're not going to do in a
really weird way I'm trying to do in a
classy way this is how I started every
business I have and have people thank me
for it the second step is that you pick
a platform all right so you have all
these contacts but you're gonna have to
pick one platform that you're gonna
start messaging or emailing them with
start with the one that you have the
most people on so if you have the most
Instagram people or you have the most
email contacts or you have more people
in your phone than any of those start
there step three but what do I say you
personalize your message so what you
want to do is you want to use something
you already know about the person or
Prospect in order to initiate reaching
out to them this is also just called
being a human being what you do is you
take 30 seconds you look at someone's
profile and you say oh they've got this
thing we have something in common and
you could reach out to them with that as
your primary message so for example you
can be like hey Saul you got a baby hey
saw you switch jobs hey saw you move hey
you saw that movie last weekend it
doesn't matter all you need to show is
that you took the few seconds to
actually not just blast some sort of
message step four you reach out and you
reach out to 100 people every single day
so let's say you had 3 000 people
between all your emails all your phone
contacts and every single follower
across all your social medias it took
you 20 years to send your first DM and
it'll take you two minutes to send the
second one everything must be hard
before it can be easy so just get over
the hump send it just something so you
can realize that you won't die step five
what do I say if they reply you warm
them up I use a framework that I call
ACA you acknowledge compliment and you
ask for example I can acknowledge and
say oh so you have two kids they're
gonna compliment about the thing so it's
like wow you have two kids you must be a
super mom working full-time and having
two kids when we go to ask we're gonna
tie our ask to the complim we just gave
them then we transition to whatever type
of question that's going to lead them to
the service we sell if I was selling
weight loss I'd be like hey so you're
Superman how do you have time to eat
right and work out wait a second this
sounds like selling it's not talking
[__] humans step six invite their
friends when you're talking about this
stuff you're not going to sell them this
is [__] cute you're not gonna solicit
them you asked a question they're going
to tell you stuff and then it's going to
be like oh yeah by the way do you know
anyone who's looking for X Y and Z
because I'm opening up a few slots to
help people do exactly that you're just
asking them if they know anybody and
since you're friends with them and since
you're contacts you're asking them for a
favor you're not asking them to buy from
you this should make you not feel weird
about messaging people if they say hey
I'd like to find out more now what they
have done is they've transitioned from a
lead to an Engaged lead a lead is
somebody that you can contact an Engaged
lead is someone who you can contact
comma who has shown interest in the
thing that you sell if she says I
haven't been able to keep up with my
workouts Etc now they have shown
interest in the thing well then how do I
get them to buy from it we're going to
give them the easiest offer in the world
to say yes to you're going to make it
free they probably know that you're not
that experienced just be honest the
reason we do it for free is you say hey
I'm gonna do all this stuff for free as
long as you promise to do three things
one you actually use my service two you
give me feedback on it and three leave a
killer review if you think it deserves
one those are the terms of exchange the
reason I want you to start with that is
that one it'll get you more reps two you
probably suck three you need to learn
how to suck less and you suck less by
doing more and it's way easier to get
more people to work with you if you
lower the barrier to free you're
actually getting the better end of the
deal you might be wondering why I just
mush the [__] out this banana in my hand
and it's because the launch of my second
book 100 million dollar leads is both
nutritious natural and uh will make you
lots of money unlike bananas but the
event itself where I'll be launching it
on Saturday August 19th will be bananas
I've spent over a million dollars in the
event itself and I'm going to be giving
away a secret thing that I've been
working on for over four years to
everyone who's there with me live and I
I would love to tell you what it is it
kills me inside that I cannot tell you
but I want the surprise itself to be
worth it and I think it will be this is
a date that you're not going to miss
it's a day after my birthday and it's my
way of giving back to you guys for being
so awesome click the link register and
I'll see you guys I'll tell you the
quick story of Warren Buffett and Ben
Graham Ben Graham was the goat back in
the day for investing Warren Buffett was
just a kid out of Columbia and wanted to
go learn investing and he offered to
work for Graham for free graham said
you're getting the better end of the
deal the actual answer was you're
overpriced so free was too expensive for
Graham because Graham knew that he was
gonna have to invest more in getting
Warren good enough to actually work for
him and so right now these customers and
they are very much customers because
they are exchanging something for your
service they're exchanging their time
and their effort and some stuff later
that you're gonna have them do just
because you're not getting paid doesn't
mean it's free but it is monetarily free
so gather round
I'm gonna give you two versions of this
you say by the way do you know anybody
who is describe their struggles looking
to dream outcome in time delay I'm
taking on five case studies for free
because that's all I can handle I just
want to get some testimonials for my
service or product and we're being
honest because this is their first
business and you [__] have no idea
what you're doing so you better not take
more than five customers I just had a
girl named XXX work with me to get dream
outcome even though she described the
same struggle the person you're talking
to is struggling with I'd like to get
more testimonials to show Works across
different scenarios does anyone you like
come to mind if they say no here's a
really funny way you can respond to that
you say haha does anyone you hate come
to mind
honestly that's when you'll sometimes
get the real response if you don't have
time to say all of those things you just
say I help the type of customer get
dream outcome in time period without
effort and sacrifice and I guarantee XYZ
to decrease risk that's it that's if you
just have that moment to deliver one
thing of what do I do some special
snowflakes are going to be like you
should never sell your time for nothing
you suck you have never done this before
so it would be unreasonable for you to
be good why would you want to sell sucky
service to people you know if people
don't want to work with you even for
free then ask them why because the
reason that someone tells you they don't
want to work with you even for free is
because there are hidden costs
associated with whatever thing you sell
if you figure out what all those hidden
costs are you can eliminate those hidden
costs and then be able to charge
significantly more for your solution
later compared to the other people who
charge for it and still include those
hidden costs so I'll give you an example
I got solicited in this exact Manner and
a guy messaged me and said I want to do
short form videos for you you don't have
to do anything I will take all the stuff
you already have online and I will make
them for you and I'll even post them for
you like you actually just need to say
yes and so I said yes and guess what you
started making short videos and he
started accepting payments because he
had removed the hidden costs if people
get value from this thing that you have
especially if it's free they're far more
likely to leave positive reviews give
you feedback and send their friends and
family once we have that we have our
first customers now we go to step eight
you start back at the top so you had
that big list and we hit all of the
months and back again so some of those
people by the way when you ask them if
they know anybody they actually just
give you people that they know that
might help and you get free leads
because if you reach out to 3 000 people
with a free thing you'll get five people
who will take you up on it I promise you
so now you're like but Alex I can't work
for free forever now we're on step nine
start charging once people start
referring that's when you know you were
good enough to start charging when this
happens all you do is you go back up to
the script that I just read to you and
you change free to 80 off and you say
that's for the next five what do you do
after that change the 80 to 60 after you
get those five change to forty then to
twenty then you're at full price but
guess what it doesn't have to stop there
you can go 20 over you can go 40 over
that because there are no rules and if
at that point you're way better you may
Merit that because of the value that you
deliver because ideally you're charging
full retail but now you're at 10x the
value value that you have done has
gotten better because you figured out
from the feedback that these people that
work with you for free have told you so
that you can make it even better for
people who pay you once you have those
people and you started transitioning
congratulations you are in business and
you are making money you will at some
point reach capacity when you fill up
all your slots with free people and
discounted people now you have true
scarcity and so you can ethically sell
with conviction that you really don't
have that much room they will desire you
more because you are scarce from a
resource perspective and then they will
pay the same or premium in order to work
with you and then you turn to your free
person and you say I am accepting
somebody who's paying full vote in order
to do this if you would like me to keep
doing this for you you would have to
start paying to match them are you
comfortable with that if they're not no
sweat because all you did is you help
them for free and you say no worries can
I get the the killer killer review you
asked me for or I asked you for and
those Free People you have to love and
cherish them more than anyone else in
your life because they're going to get
you business in three different ways one
They're Gonna Leave You reviews that are
going to get your best too they're gonna
send you people that are going to get
your business and three they themselves
May transition into paying you which
will also get you busy don't think short
think long and you'll make long money
now you have paying customers you're
reaching your capacity you're
consistently raising your price because
now there is more demand than you have
Supply and we have artificially created
a condition for profit so what's the 10
step keep them warm you've got this big
list of people check in like a human
being provide value to them on a regular
basis when you do that you continue to
reinforce and deposit Goodwill in the
audience because what will happen
eventually is you won't even need to ask
them because you've provided enough
value you start posting enough
testimonials enough results talking
about some of the insurance stuff that
you're doing right now that people be
like hey that's actually pretty cool hey
can I find out more about that and then
they'll actually start soliciting you
and that's the game that's how you go
from zero to hero and get your first
five paying customers